it's such a pleasure I'm a huge Beauty
and the Beast fan and I know you are too
I mean did Little Gabby Wilson ever
imagine that she would be a Disney
princess oh my gosh she didn't she
didn't and um it's something I think
every little girl wants to be and I'm a
huge huge Disney fan and Disney princess
fan so the fact that it's happening I'm
like wow I'm pinching myself and with
this insane cast too like it's crazy who
are you the most Starstruck by oh my
gosh all of them I know right I mean
Shania Twain because I love Shania Twain
but like also watching David Alan Grier
Martin Short interact and then Josh
Groban he's so sweet and so kind so it's
it's um it's an amazing amazing group I
feel like you had a bunch of Pinchy
moments as you're working on this
project but like when you put on the
Bell costume and walk out for the first
time what does that feel like I'm like
because of that moment I am walking
differently I feel like
I can't explain it but it's it's like uh
it's a new kind of confidence and and I
really love that and um yeah it just
feels good to be a Disney princess it's
one of the most fun things I've ever
done in my life so yeah was it the most
scary thing you've done in your life too
or no not necessarily scary hectic for
sure and um I was a little nervous but
the excitement kind of made the nerves
go away you owned it is what it sounds
like you owned it I think I do and the
timing of this is so insane and so
perfect actually the time of this is
poetic because you're also ready to come
out and you know go by your real name
Gabriella Wilson and now you have this
new confidence too so what is this next
era of Gabriella Wilson look like you
know it's it's the beginning of so many
other things I've I've kept it about the
music for so long and now it's time for
people to get to know the person behind
the music and you know see all the other
things that I love like being a Disney
princess and um Color Purple is coming
out so there's so many projects that I'm
looking forward to you know whether I'm
producing or acting in and yeah it's
going to be a great time could we ever
see you on a Broadway stage maybe
because we know you're one Tony shy of
that egot status no you never know oh
you never know we'll see I mean does
that trip you out to know like first of
all congratulations thank you so much it
was so unexpected I was like oh my gosh
it's crazy I'm not even a part of this
like you want to know me uh and I'm sure
you never had that on your like vision
board no no I mean of course you hope
for the egot when you conquer one thing
and then the other but um no it was
never like a goal of mine I'm just happy
to be doing what I love and then getting
recognized for it it must be a sign that
you uh got to work on this with a fellow
egot winner Rita Moreno I'm just gonna
put that out there yeah I love Rita
she's so amazing like definitely an
inspiration
foreign
[Music]